SPEAKER 1: Publishing
a new app or releasing
a new version of an app
is an exciting moment
for every developer.
It's a critical moment when
you have to pay attention
to all the details to make sure
your users will have the best
experience with your app.
To make this process
easier, we're
announcing a new way to publish
apps-- the Manage Releases
page in the Google
Play Developer Console.
You start by creating
a new app listing.
Click Create
Application, and you
can access the new Manage
Releases page in the left side
nav.
It takes you to this page which
shows the tracks to which you
can publish your app--
the production, beta,
and alpha tracks.
Of course, we recommend running
a beta test for all your apps.
It's a great way to test new
features before you launch them
publicly.
If it's your first release,
the page will be empty.
And you need to select a
track to create the release.
For example, select
Manage Production and then
New Release.
Clicking on Upload APK
will open the usual pop-up.
And you can pick the
file you want to upload.
After uploading the APK,
it shows up in the APKs
to Add section.
The release name is
filled in with the version
name from the uploaded APK.
And if you're releasing
an app update,
don't forget to
fill in the What's
New section in the release.
You also get the chance
to provide localization
for all the
languages you already
support in your app listing.
And one of the best things about
the new Manage Releases flow
is that at any moment, you can
save your draft release date
and you can work on other
parts of the listing
and come back to
finish it later.
To resume to your save
state, navigate back
to Manage Releases, Manage
Production, and hit Resume.
Once the release is
ready to be published,
you can click on
Review, and you'll
be presented with a
summary of the release.
If you've got no
validation errors,
click on Confirm Rollout
to publish your app.
And you'll be redirected
to the Releases page.
The flow is slightly different
if you're updating an existing
app, because when you choose
your track and click on New
Release, a new draft is
created, like before,
but the draft is based
on the previous release.
The APKs of the previous
release will all
be added to the list
of APKs to deactivate.
Of course, if you want, you
can choose to retain them.
Click the Retain button.
And you'll keep the old
APKs because maybe they're
providing support for
earlier API versions.
You can add as many APKs
you want at this stage.
And for each upload,
you'll see a basic pop-up
with information about the APK.
And it's here that you can
also attach expansion files.
When you are done with
new APKs, like before,
you can edit the release
name and the What's New.
After filling in
all the information,
you're ready to
review your release.
If you're releasing on
the production track,
you can change your
rollout percentage directly
in this summary screen.
Rolling out your app gradually
is a recommended best practice,
and it has been for
a while, especially
for significant app releases.
It helps you identify
problems and fix them
before your app update
hits 100% of the user base,
helping avoid bad
reviews and low ratings.
You can read more
about staged rollouts
in the Google Play
Developer Help Center.
Now, whenever you're ready,
you can adjust your rollout
percentage by clicking
on Update Rollout
and just changing the value.
If you have any doubts about
what percentage to use,
we have suggestions
there for you.
So if you have any problems
on your ongoing stage rollout,
it's now easier than
ever to halt it.
Just click on the Halt Rollout
button and confirm the action.
It's worth being aware that
halting a stage rollout out
will prevent new
users from being
able to update to this version.
But users who already have the
bad update will still have it.
So make sure you introduce
the fix as quickly as you can.
Once you've got the fix,
create another release,
upload it, and then
roll out that release.
Simply keep the
bad release halted.
Of course, if the fix was made
without creating a new release,
maybe you fixed it
on your servers.
You can just choose to hit
Resume Rollout at any point.
Another new feature
we're launching
to help give you greater
control over the releases
is the Artifact Library.
Artifacts include
APKs, expansion files,
and any other app files.
And you can see the update
in the apps artifacts
if you go to the Artifact
Library under Manage Releases.
You'll see everything uploaded
with your release app.
With the new Manage
Releases functionality,
managing your app release is
now smoother, more transparent,
and easier to track.
It gives you the ability
to manage your app releases
with more confidence.
[MUSIC PLAYING]